>> Similar to Groundhog rules
shattering your clavicle
on a rope swing means
summer is officially over.
Nope. Nope, nope, nope,
Oh! Oh! Oh!
Oh!
[Bleep]
Go on, go quick, go.
Oh my God.
>> Summer time is a joke
in this country.
You know what the dumbest kids
in the planet don't deserve?
A three month vacation.
♪ It's Autumn time
we don't like it at all. ♪
♪ It's Autumn time can we
just call it freaking Fall? ♪
I think a good rule of thumb
is if Eminem won't say
you probably shouldn't say it
in your sophomore English class.
I ill never say
any form of nigga.
I'm cured of that. Starting now.
I'm never saying it again.
This fall the wardrobe will be
over priced concert tees.
Wait. With sexy stubble.
Welcome to High school Gameday
brought you by Clearasil.
and Planned Parenthood Beaver
said, "Me and My Girl
are going to have lots of sex
watching Tosh Point.0.
When we want to laugh.
We'll watch the Daily Show."
That's okay, that's okay.
Time to say goodbye
to rope swing season
[awww] And hello
to roof job season!
Oh no no, Mom help help!
Don't be a pussy! yeah, yeah!
Yeaaah!! oh!!! >>
Finally it's your last chance
to get one more
BBQ in before the summer ends.
So get those weenies
on the grill.
A Nice char will offset
the taste of burning pubes.
Don't prick it all the juices
will run out.
If she done?
Go ahead and stick that
on my toasted buns.
It helps to butter them first.